season to the burner show baby we're now
late no mother could tell me what an
animal style burger actually is right if
they haven't watched the last season my
burger quest brought me to New York City
to suck up some East Coast flavor but
when it comes to Burger culture let's be
real dude
la is ground zero that's why I'm heading
back home to show you what it's all
about it's California you got beautiful
weather you got beautiful women you got
low riders and then you got brothers
Matt we'll let you see our car you let
us see that Burger Tommy is a secret
handshake the late-night spot fresh out
of a game you come and straight get
burgers and fries they need to have beer
and they'll be lit can't go wrong with
Tommy's though let's go eat that's
Tommy's baby Gunilla field we are at the
mecca of West Coast burger at the Apple
pen I could start to cry just thinking
about it if you know you know and if you
don't I have to show you what's up
the patty melt is back there is a little
bit of a legacy to this I love burgers
if I equally love patty Mouser both are
children you got love with Angie let's
grab some burgers let's go see God there
you go
internet I know you're gonna hate us and
if you hate us go yourselves underneath
you